adopter un animal beaucoup en rêvent
dans le cadre du mois de l'adoption les
équipes de la spa sont mobilisés pour
accueillir les futurs adoptants et pour
certaines familles qui souhaitent un
animal aller dans un refuge est une
évidence trouve que c'est important il
ya des chiens qui sont engagés autant
leur donner leur chance plutôt qu'à les
voir directement les éleveurs et
prendront fio mais adopter un animal est
une décision qui doit être mûrement
réfléchie pour éviter les abandons
l'adoption doit être responsable pour
faire vraiment attention il faut
réfléchir faut penser à tout pour passer
au plan b pour les vacances sont lancés
à plein de choses faut penser au budget
que ça représente parce que c'est pas
non plus anodin c'est pas juste un
paquet de croquettes tous les mois donc
il faut vraiment bien réfléchir avant d
adopter et donc je pense que nous on est
bon la spa constate une baisse des
abandons de chiens de 14%
malheureusement la situation est bien
différente pour les chats on a beaucoup
de chatons ce qui est dû au fait que les
stérilisations n'ont pas pu avoir lieu
pendant tout le confinement
donc il ya une dérive et de soit on en
as
tous les jours on a des appels pour des
chatons trouvait malheureusement n'est
pas en capacité de tous les accueillir
et on en cruellement de famille relaie
aussi pour pouvoir les accueillir
or refuge face à ce nombre croissant de
chats abandonnés
la spa un message clair faites
stériliser vos animaux quoi fait les
stériliser parce que là c'est une
catastrophe au niveau des chatons c'est
vraiment c'est pareil au niveau national
quoi on a tous été débordé par par les
arrivées de chatons qui sont en plus
malade la plupart au total la spa espère
trouver grâce à ce mois de l'adoption
3300 famille